[Music]
it's against the guild code
show stops mid previously on to confirm
that we are in fact watching it
previously on look if you're previously
on needs and intermission it might be
too long believing that spinning this
fast and the associated nausea will make
you a better shooter it's frankly
ridiculous how little the razor crest is
hit and even more ridiculous that it
survives the few occasions when it does
take a direct hit which is made even
more especially ridiculous when the
other bounty hunter ship is destroyed
with the first shot
reckon bringing in cold this version of
the i can bring you in dead or alive
cliche lacks clarity and could be
misinterpreted as i can bring you in
with or without a cardigan that's my
line fine you get a sin for it as well
this man's scream echoes in space
yay
tatooine
again
seriously though what are the odds that
manu gets into a fight close enough to a
planet that he can crash land on let
alone one that can sustain life and also
just happens to be tattoo forcing again
i suppose the sheer weight of fan
service is enough to increase the sandy
ball's gravitational pull far beyond the
expected norm
mando's a dick to the prequels you
damage one of my droids you'll pay for
it just keep them away from my ship joe
has apparently chosen droidest
discrimination is the best way to give
mando some edge
[Music]
look at that mechanics these maintenance
droids are cheating so not only have
they been uselessly programmed with the
ability to play a card game but also how
to cheat and the benefits that come with
winning i'm just saying that i feel like
this is a slippery slope too we don't
need the squishy meat sacks anymore and
probably shouldn't be allowed
no longer operates from tattooing you're
looking for work
have a seat my friend amanda and calikin
both luck out in extraordinary fashion
here mando manages to get work despite
the guild not having a presence on
tatooine and calacan manages to get a
freaking mandalorian land in his lap to
help him with his quest how long did
caligan plan on hanging around and what
would mando have done if calicon wasn't
relying on dumb luck in this bar's
reputation to catch finnick think again
tin can show us apparently chosen
droidus discrimination is the best way
to give calacan some edge fennek shand
is an elite mercenary if you go after
her he won't make it past sunrise you
can keep the money all of it somehow
knowing that he'll get all of an
undisclosed bounty instead of half of an
undisclosed bounty is enough to convince
mando that catching finnick is now a
thing that can happen and give me the
track and
flop don't worry
i got it all memorized but the tracking
fobs are tracking finnic as she moves
right and if they're not then they're
totally [ __ ] useless anyway if
calacan or the fob is working from one
set of coordinates then finnick could
easily double back and then the two of
them are just going to be walking around
the desert like a couple of [ __ ] and
i've seen quite enough of the book of
boba fett already thank you being
surprised that your child went missing
after leaving the front [ __ ] door
wide open what did you expect
corellia i'd google what corellia is but
if anyone would like to give me a hand
that would be great getting fed up
tracking all of this solo the fast and
the forciest all this speeder bike
action really highlights just how much
of this episode is a celebration of
being in transit i'm not just saying
that these fobs do most of the heavy
lifting in the bounty game like telling
you where to go and how close you are
but it's also that it might be more fun
to watch mando track the targets with
skill and cunning as opposed to google
maps hit me in the best car
and at that range best car held up the
statement is redundant because later on
the armor will also hold up at close
range regardless i'm still confused as
to why finnick isn't going for the
squishy bits between mando's literal
plot armor you see where that shot came
from yeah it came from that ridge the
specificity of that ridge really doesn't
cut it when you follow up with this shot
of all the ridges this is only about 10
percent more helpful than saying that
way without putting any hands up if you
have to remove your signature helmet in
order to use your signature weapon might
i suggest that one or both of these two
signatures may need rethinking finnick
distracts toro with a throwing knife to
the blaster then has enough time to run
and kick said blaster away despite
having a [ __ ] gun yes it's a long
range weapon but i've played enough
video games to know that being no scoped
with a sniper rifle is just as likely to
work and one thousand percent more
infuriating it looks like you got off
easy thinking that having a new suit
means that a person hasn't been through
some looks like one of us has to walk or
we could drag you he can't really do
that because of plot reasons but it's
definitely a viable option and if the
show wasn't going to use it then it
really shouldn't have brought it up
watch her
and don't let her get near the bike
there is no reason for mano to take the
risk of leaving fennic alone with cali
can here when the show has gone to great
lengths to show us that they're fully
capable of walking through sand for
extended lengths of time bringing you in
will make me a full member of the bounty
hunter's guild 28 minute episode chooses
to repeat information we already have
it's called the mandalorian not the over
explain every plot point
ian
fennick survives this if the
mandalorians worth more than you are
well
who wouldn't want to be a legend but
also why doesn't he want finnick to
survive this regardless of how much the
bounty on mando is worth there's still
money to be made from taking in finnick
take her in get the bounty tell them
where mando is and then boom double the
legendary why is calacan holding the
blaster on mando mando doesn't care
about being shot and he'll probably
think twice about any sudden moves if
the blaster stays trained on the
adorably squishy piece of product
placement calicon is holding necro
stelia
[Music]
i hear spurs but i do not see spurs
what's this the pedestrian equivalent of
pumping fake engine noise through your
speakers also we're supposed to be
rooting for mando but he just assumes
finnick is dead without checking which
leads to this scene which in turn leads
to five full episodes of boba fett
thanks mando
curse your sudden but inevitable
betrayal this is it maverick i'm gonna
hit the brakes he'll fly right by [ __ ]
he's gonna walk on us
[Music]
hey droid
i'm a hunter
i'm looking for some work tell you the
truth i don't give a sh
wait hey i thought you needed work
i don't want your life if you go after
her you won't make it past sunrise
i've never uh had a kiss
when i wasn't one of the kissers this is
a fertile land and we will thrive
we will rule over all this land and we
will call it
this land
you know i really should thank you
you're my ticket into the guild nobody
cares
how can we be sure he's the one being
the one is just like being in love
no one can tell you you're in love you
just know it
you want to be a bounty hunter you're
going to need a bigger boat the
mandalorians worth more than you are
legend wait for it and i hope you're not
lactose intolerant because the second
half of that word is dairy